الى جانب اخر او من جانب اخر من جوانب حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث اعلن نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي الكسندر جراشكو تمديد
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب من الموانئ الاوكرانيه
60 يوما ووصف الكرمله هذه الخطوه بانها
بادره حسن نيه من قبل روسيا واعرب عن امله
في تنفيذ الجزء الثاني من الاتفاق الذي
يتضمن ازاله القيود المفروضه على تصدير
المنتجات الزراعيه الروسيه
من جهته قال وزير البنيه التحتيه
الاوكراني
ان موقف روسيا من تمديد صفقه الحبوب لستين
يوما فقط يتعارض مع اتفاقها مع تركيا
والامم المتحده ووفقا للوزير فان السلطات
الاوكرانيه تنتظر ردا من تركيا والامم
المتحده بشان التصريحات الروسيه بينما
نقلت رويترز عن مسؤول حكوميا اوكرانيا
انكيف تلتزم تماما ببنود الاتفاق الذي وقع
العام الماضي والذي ينص على تمديد لمئه
وعشرين يوما كما ذكرت وزاره الدفاع
التركيه ان المحادثات بشان تمديد اتفاق
الحبوب لا تزال مستمره الموقف ذاته اكده
المتحدث باسم الامم المتحده الذي قال ان
المشاورات بشان التمديد مستمره مع كل
الاطراف